von daher machen uns ein eisen nicht
weil die reisen wollen sondern einfach
weil wir zeigen wollen herr kummer wir
haben riesenkröten das ist der
hauptgrund bei ladies and gentlemen ganz
deutschland habe erstmal und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge vom
mega projekt zusammen mit mir selber
weil ich möchte etwas machen und zwar
ein bisschen trollen
ich war ja jetzt nicht auf den server
ich war ja jetzt die letzten tage immer
mal so oft dass im live stream hat mich
beitritts blicken lassen
deswegen haben wir eine menge
hingekriegt zum beispiel habe ich auch
hingekriegt dass das tech speck
vernünftig läuft das muss ich erstmal
alles aufbauen
nur die solarpanels die gegen ihn wie
immer noch nicht und ich habe das jetzt
erstmal alles neu installiert habe jetzt
auch noch kein ob tief anderen deswegen
lasse ich das gerade erst ein bisschen
aufbauen das ist jetzt nicht alle zu
mega hakt und direkt an zu regnen
mit der nicht auskommen mit dem ring
ich habe in der letzten folge in dieser
1 stunden folge den ritter boss besiegt
das heißt ich muss mein keller gleich
erst ein bisschen aufräumen
allerdings wollte ich auch noch mal die
meinung dann schmeißen die mir dass hier
zwei höher machen soll warum zwei höre
eigentlich will ich noch einen höhe aber
er kann das gleich von zwei höher machen
weil ich da auch noch schwarz blöcke
oben drauf packen möchte als dingsbums
oder mabel halt als decken belagerung
ich bin noch am überlegen das alles
einfach weiß zu machen weil ich glaube
dass er auch ihn wie geil aus aber ich
lasse es jetzt erstmal so weiter als
gerade erst so gemacht habe plan für
heute ist erstmal ich werde meine portal
ganze becken gern machen
das heißt ich gebe mal eben bacon
das tier
wir geben die einfach so mit zwei werken
stück ach so ja einfach einen bacon
jagdlich und dann hab ich den becken
dann deine bacon hat die eigenschaft
dass ist customize zitierte blabla
portale sind die für jeden gleich sind
sage ich mal also nicht für jeden gleich
sondern wenn ich beispielsweise einen
portal mache damit dann kann es sein das
ist die gleiche farbe hat wie das von
einem anderen aber es ist halt nicht in
dem selben in derselben frequenz sage
ich mal ich muss man eben irgendwie
schafft wildschwein töten oder so weil
sonst kriege ich hier eigentlich gar
nichts hin beziehungsweise machen das
ist echt traurig ich habe nicht mal
bacon alter dann wollte ich auch in
dieser aufnahme noch eben schnell was
heißt eben schnell ich wollte ein paar
machen dies allerdings nicht so heftig
oder zum fest ihr blut das zutreffen ist
egal ich brauche den wir die schweine
kuhlemann den regen gar nicht dass er
gut eine eisen farm ist nicht so
aufwendig muss ich echt sagen also nur
diese diamond bleibt und sixt ruder oder
die schnelle sex oder wie das heißt
muss ich mir auch noch machen und halte
goldpreis habe ich schon eine menge
kisten minimums dann habe ich einen mini
um das minimum stein habe ich eine menge
glaube ich
und ich habe rob oakeshott auch bacon
vince gebraten ist so das heißt sie
machen jetzt neuerdings kann und dann
würde ich sagen wenn ich dann die alten
formen habe wollte ich einen angriff auf
debitor sandwiches machen weil ich
einfach in gelöst habt ein bisschen hier
herumzutollen
und zwar habe ich da was witziges vor
ich werde nämlich alle umlaufen
ich weiß dass ich dabei mehrmals
draufgehen werde wahrscheinlich aber
egal mein chef ist also ich vermute es
wegen dachte ich kann man die mit dem
bogen abschießen wollte halt gleich noch
aus finden
ich möchte eigentlich ich werd scho ich
glaub ich bin mir schon wieder auch
diese hose ich bin mir schon sicher dass
diese aufnahme er wieder 20 30 minuten
lang gehen wird obwohl ich immer noch in
der hoffnung dass das einfach vielleicht
hoffentlich nicht so lange dauern wird
naja so ich mache jetzt erstmal ne
portal gun er geht die sonne unter da
geht die sonne auf die geht unter dass
der schritt von von firma herr so geil
und hier ist jetzt immer noch warten das
sinn macht das immer noch bei simon ja
geil
so warte guckt jetzt kann ich mir meine
ich möchte mein grundstück zack damit
ich noch nicht sagt und nachhaltig zu
blöd und ich bin da so als blöd dass ich
das andere portale aber das kann ich
jetzt nicht mehr weg naja ich hab eine
bacon
denn da da so durch das denn da reinigte
die portugal ein tor
hier kommen tiere du nicht aber du
kommst nämlich da rein so so ich hoffe
mal der regen hat jetzt auch weil das
diese ich hasse diese regen stimmung in
minecraft manchmal ist das geil wenn es
schneit und man in der schneeregens aber
sonst ist es doof und der regen er hört
auf gleisen fahren
auch das dach sind das loch stopfen
einfach später england reisen farm ich
brauche einen 2 0-sieg studios am besten
sechs sogar pisten glaskinn das heißt
habe ich noch bestens ich habe da wohl
noch ich habe keine bestens ja girl luca
girl bist du hier geht der nummer ist
dann ich vergesse es echt immer wieder
cobblestone redstone
red
heißes eisen
so weisen redstone zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack wisse was ich mache
gleich zehn pisten ist einfach dass es
relativ egal ich brauche demnächst noch
welche kommt auch wieder ein baum habe
ich eigentlich meine ganzen crêpes in
meinem inventar ist der schreck mächtig
auf
so kristens habe ich so wieder zurück
zum ekel extruders extra so pisten glas
glas glas lassen
doch noch glaube ich irgendwo dadurch
noch 7 glas und damit stark ein glas
mehr als nur noch zu wenig klasse ich
brauche aber zweimal 6 also 12 also mehr
als ich habe das ist natürlich nicht so
weil ich hasste warum habe ich mir dass
viele glasscheiben macht alter sogar so
viel mehr als ich überhaupt braucht hier
ich bin traum so blöd bay
ich habe ja nicht mal sand ich bin gut
im plan auf jeden fall das es übrigens
alles von der aktion von von links hatte
ich so viele bögen dadurch so viele
ich denke mal dass das glas aber es ist
einfach kein glas schaut traurig so
kommt kann man dass das ist echt traurig
wo ich muss immer noch da hinten die
comics von hier einfach ein bisschen
sonst und rangiert der lk 4 hier auch
noch ob alles aus wissenschaftlichen
zwecken euch dass ihr ab das müsste
eigentlich erst mal reichen
das ist bei sony die hatte ich auch
schon so mit einer treppe die habe ich
hier auch schon angefangen aber hier
kommt jetzt in den induktionsherd am 12
glas und pisten habe ich bin habe ich
auch nötig wären redstone auch wieder
glas ja geil
sechs davon habe ich jetzt auch jetzt
brauche ich noch maschinen frame und
gold glas
alles beruht auf glas fick dich okay ich
brauche noch mehr jungs wohl platt ich
brauche wie viel glas brauche ich denn
jetzt brauche dafür auf jeden fall schon
mal zwölf und dafür vier mal sechs sind
24 das jetzt 36
ich habe schon 18 das heißt noch mal 18
sandkuhl geil freut mich also was
wieviel war das jetzt mal zu 18 sagen ja
ich seh schon kommen alter ich werde
allein fürs craften schon wieder so
lange brauchen dass die folge eine halbe
stunde dann gehen wir aber ich wollte
eigentlich noch pumpen gehen und nein
schön publizist jungs 18 neues holen und
das 18
sogar 19 luca du bist so cool ist auch
nicht so dass ich irgendwann mal sand
irgendwie aufholen glas mittlerweile
viele brauchen oder so ähnlich wie immer
wieder neu los welcher penner
wer hat diese scheiß gold abgebaut
abgebaut
egal wie crazy nicht mehr links
tischmann arbeit von war es egal von
firma her
die schon tief gekommen muss man schon
sein
die kenne ich eigentlich auch mal mama
die jetzt kann ich endlich solarpanels
oben nimmt damit die ju meter vom noch
besser läuft apropos meter läuft beim ju
motorsports von firma herr so
glas glas glas gibt mir glas gold
brauche ich gold eisen gold glas soda
habe ich die sechs so das heißt ich
könnte eigentlich jetzt direkt loslegen
hat mal testen kommt doch da oben hier
genau da das war doch da stand das nicht
erzählen war das okay ich habe sechs
davon so das ist schon mal so die grund
sache die man braucht dafür jetzt zeige
ich euch mal welches weiter geht wie wir
weiter kraft müssen und zwar brauche ich
jetzt auf jeden fall bodentransport
pipes cobblestone brauche ich nehme
komme ich nehm gold ich hab so viel gold
alter wir können ich mir und diamond
brauche ich auch was ich auch brauche es
ganz normale kisten am besten ein
goldküste ich nehme einfach die da
hinten steht und was ich auch noch
brauche ist ein auto crafting tableaux
der ist glaube ich relativ einfach auto
crafting table whittier crafting table
wuttke jetzt habe ich gleich noch eine
menge mehr hab ich nicht ab
hab ich nix gut gehe
und ein schaf king day will mehrere fünf
müssten erstmal reichen so luca betreibt
wieder mit vips so auto crafting table
habe ich jetzt
du kommst mit nein das war falsch so ihr
kommt hier rein ziehen lassen nicht das
glas ist kommt ein glas ist ab wenn wir
uns mal bonn und redstone engine fällt
mir dazu ein
redstone engine und lämmer brauche ich
auch redstone engine watch plank alter
alles beruht auf glas lag nicht am arsch
ich hole mir jetzt richtig viel pech als
erst mal so und dabei gehen jetzt erst
mal eine wüste ach leute ich wollte so
schnell fertig sein damit und es dauert
einfach so lange wieder
aber egal wir haben ja eine kontingenz
von daher sollte das ganze ein bisschen
schneller gehen die ganze reise und so
was alles mein ziel ist dann auch wieder
dass ich mir ganz viel konnte mscusa
weiter geht schneller hiermit dass
abzubauen den gibt es nicht schade habe
ich nicht eine mit efficient ziehen
es ist doch egal das ziel ist ja erst
mal dass ich meine komplette quantel
engels mache allerdings hole ich mir
jetzt erstmal eine eisen fahren weil aus
eisen kann man dann auch ganz ganz viel
gold machen und gold braucht man oft so
viele sachen es auf dauer auch so
wertvoll
deswegen ist es eigentlich relativ egal
was ich mir zuerst seine reisen haben
sich doch immer vor den anderen
mitspielern zu hey guck mal der heftig
was gemacht mit pipes der hat dicke eier
in der hose
von daher machen uns ein eisen nicht
weil bereisen wollen sondern einfach
weil wir zeigen wollen herr kummer wir
haben riesenkröten das ist der
hauptgrund
dann läuft auf jeden fall bei uns so ich
glaube jetzt alles ab nicht irgendwie so
damit die wüste schön aussieht ich mache
das hier einfach nur damit dass die
scheiße und so weiter irgendwann wetter
leck mich am arsch ich will kein stress
new york main standard ipv6 anders teil
anderthalb sechs anderthalb sind wollen
wir mal kommen wir setzen wir machen wir
trollen hier gleich mal ein bisschen rum
bzw in der nächsten folge ich schaue ich
das mache ich mal wieder so eine xxl
folge die letzte kann relativ gut an
so leute wir können dann eigentlich
leicht auch direkt schon anfangen was
man jetzt eigentlich wollte das and
often schmeißen so du kommst da rein und
du da hat jeder hier gleich viel und
dann wollte ich eine redstone engine
porn braucht das wort gier und auch
testen sales nicht so viel gemacht
ich packe ich erst mal kurz hier vorne
im bereich bad english ein ei wie geht's
eigentlich hier
braun hole es weiß geworden
hey hey girl das weißt du nie weißt ich
wollte auch noch ich wollte jeden
eigentlich so ein bisschen träumen
übrigens die outlaws sind ja wieder in
der stadt angekommen
ich wollte eigentlich alle mal so ein
bisschen trollen und dann so höre hier
konnte bedeutet alles nach dem motto
muss man schauen was da traut wert also
ich hab hier noch so viele generate as
one place habe ich gar nicht so listen
und ich brauche mehr gut gehen
dede definitiv der fall ist ich brauche
und place brauche ich aber allgemein und
auch hier für uns war da oben drauf ich
brauche nämlich 1 3412 woche 76 77
ebenso aus den beiden mache ich mir nix
fix bis zum umfallen so und daraus mache
ich mir jetzt dauern bis die stars
kommen hierhin und in astronomische muss
einfach nur ist natürlich so als habe
ich sieben zu ihr kommt hier raus jetzt
können wir theoretisch loslegen als
durch noch levy macht mir dann noch mal
clever und ich brauch noch lava und
wasser fällt mir auch noch auf fax es
geht nicht so schnell
was so kommen ist dann einfach ich
beeile mich ja schon die ganze zeit ich
bin ja produktiv ist hell gerade aber
ich brauche auch sieben schalter klar
kann man die ganzen sache nie wieder die
ich jetzt erst mal wieder nicht brauche
wie zum beispiel sony glas und stec
kommt das fand ich auch eigentlich immer
ich brauche noch eine neue kiste wo ich
so wertvolle sachen reihen tour fällt
mir dazu ein so extruder erstens brauche
ich auch nicht
jetzt brauche ich die brauche ich
brauche ich nicht sind auch nicht
wertvoll
die kiste brauche ich definitiv die auch
glas ach ich vergaß karotten zum fräsen
natürlich mal so ein bisschen habe ich
dilemma dabei die habe ich ja ich
brauche es ist ja ich brauch lava und
ich brauche besser einmal eine menge
schweiß egal ich brauche definitiv 1 2 3
4 5 6 und mache erstmal wasserladungen
dann noch eine ladung datei ist
ich brauch 6 also 1 2 3 4 5 1 oder 5 1 2
3 4 5
so kann ich dann zurück tun dann bricht
das ganze jetzt ich baue das erstmal auf
beziehungsweise ich komm jetzt einfach
mal von innen dem wasser wo ihr kommen
hierbei kev der mac hat doch eh nicht
dass er im urlaub
der hat ja hier allerdings eine farm
zack zack zack zack zack
so geht's
so wir bauen das ganze jetzt auf und
zwar bei euch das einfach mal habe ich
das aufbauen
ich brauche das erste mal hatte wenn ich
hier so bin
danke übrigens an die person die mir das
geschickt hatte ich glaub ich hab sogar
die video antwort akzeptiert weil ich
das echt cool fand dass ihr mir da so
sachen geschickt habt ihr jetzt braucht
das ganze erstmal auf das wird also
wasser und lava uns war es alles braucht
später dann zum befüllen und zwar packen
jetzt hier die diamondbacks drauf die
das ganze aus den angel sich rudolf
rauss pumpen
dann packen wir hier die golden peaks
dran wo das dann durch gepumpt wird so
was im moment brauchen wir gar nicht
gehen zack gehen wir einfach hier so hin
so hatte noch ein runter noch mensch
sondern auch als falsch dann kommen hier
nämlich die auto crafting table dran mit
denen armenien stein motto crafting
table lässt
jetzt kommt hier wurden transport pipe
da wurden transport halbzeit raus dann
kommt hier eine goldkette um das
weiterzuleiten dann kommt die wieder so
ein auto kräftig table dann kommt ihr
wieder nur wurden dann ne goldene kalb
dann nochmal autokrat dann kein auto
kräfte doch doch otto crafting table
aber keine testwahl die chest muss nur
hier dran dann hier wieder eine wurden
dann das war zehnmal also ist die
ethnisches extruder die sind dafür da
dass darin wasser und lava reinkommen
eine ladung dann entsteht dann
cobblestone der kommisson wird dann
hierdurch befördert durch die golden
denkbar dann lege ich hier ein rezept
rennen das aus korb ist so blind wird so
das geht dann hier in auckland wird klar
hier wird aus claim-blöcke dafür
brauchen aber keine mini um steinbach in
die kiste muss beim mini mini um stein
dann kommt hier kostenblöcke und dann
kommt hier noch mal ein crafting table
damals aber wieder mini um stein rein
und dann ist fertig schon bambus wurden
transport pumpt er das in eine kiste die
dann hier hinten steht
und zwar eine die hier so und dann haben
wir da quasi in die eisen fan ich kaufe
das weil es nicht im weg zu viel und das
alles richtig war
und naja jedenfalls müssen wir diese
popstar betreiben und zwar das der typ
in sein wieder ein bisschen umständlich
gemacht und zwar der elektriker engines
genommen allerdings brauchen die kohle
und der marathon engines nimmt die
laufen halt einfach so deswegen stellen
wir haben also ein paar hin einfach und
zwar übertreibe ich ja immer gerne das
wisst ihr und hier brauchen am anfang
eine menge los war falsch klick dich
spiel so der kommt hier hin
darunter kommt selbstverständlich ein
schalter und ich muss mir auch wieder
die hochbahn clubs schalter so
und dies jetzt an so das gleiche kommt
hier auch so und hier auch so
ich will den schalter auch hier so cool
gelegt haben nein nein nein
kriege ich nicht ich will dass der
andersrum steht du verdammt war so die
sind jetzt erstmal alle angetrieben das
reicht da erst mal so hier muss auch
hier reicht es wenn du eine redstone
dingsbums star ist stelle ich einfach
mal hier hin
jetzt ist er wieder so für mich
verschärfen
hier reicht die braucht man euch gar
keine
obwohl ich glaube auch über alleine nur
hinten braucht man halt keine ich stelle
einfach überall hin
hier kommst du hin so so da ist jetzt
natürlich aber noch nichts drin weil wir
brauchen erstmal mini um steine und noch
koppel stones und das rezept festzulegen
so cobblestone brauche ich ich brauche
flint habe ich hab doch eine menge
flinte hat dich nicht mal eine menge
hatte ich nicht eine menge flint ich
hatte doch mal hatte die wahl ganz viel
habe ich nun mal bin ich denn ich bin
ich bildet bemüht flint nedas kanzlerin
dass die flächen stil das zweifelt
erstmal ja ich brauche aber 4
das 1 lind kommt später folgen noch
flint haben alter das muss ich jetzt
kreml hinstellen und abbauen alter ja ok
ich muss kribbelig stellen abbauen geil
travel.com ich glaub irgendwo wird der
wolf hinteren sein oder gar nicht geht
mir flint relevanter 2,3 play wieder ins
leder direkt übermütig so mini um steine
also warte ich legt schon mal hier die
rezepte rein und zwar muss hier erstmal
zum cobblestone rezept rein so daraus
wird dann fehlen sondern muss hier das
blind rezept fallen daraus wird dann
clay
deswegen brauche ich jetzt noch clay und
claim blöcke deswegen suche ich mal ganz
kurz das kein catering übrigens das mit
doppelklick dass er so sucht wenn sich
irgendeiner frage wahrscheinlich egal ob
fragen wird ist auch kein fehler drin
und ich auch nicht aber nicht görlich
kann direkt auch gleich fahren gehen so
eher egal denke ich erst mal kurz plate
farben dann braucht die farm halt noch
ein bisschen und lava brauche ich auch
noch dann ich gehe einfach in der hölle
dann für lover oder also ich glaube das
wäre somit das sinnvoll zu sein eigenes
höhlen portal wollte ich mir auch noch
machen
ich will immer mehr zwar erlaubt dass er
durch sein kann und hat dadurch halt
auch ein nachteil und was alles aber
trotzdem sein eigenes auch immer cool so
weil es schwebt übrigens überall diese
scheiß magie zeugs rum eltern auch
irgendwie doof mit magie werden wir auch
bald anfangen aber erstmal jetzt hier
noch so ein bisschen bisschen
energietechnisch technik mäßig sonja ist
doch ich muss doch irgendwo noch clay
drumherum liegen oder ich brauche kein
ob die finderin also ich kann unter
wasser so schlecht sehen da ist clay
girl so ich brauche gar nicht so viel
ich brauch nur so viel dass sich halt
ich brauche hier und dann nochmal 4 x 4
720 ich habe 24 uhr perfekt
aber da waren wir schon welche weil das
den weg darüber ich glaub ich war hier
schon mal so sogar ich jetzt aber mehr
durch
ich glaube dann ist man mit quantums
tuttlingen schneller oder ist man
schneller wenn man jetpacks lied ich
glaub konnte im skoda obwohl jetpack
sieht immer so langsam aus aber das ist
eigentlich auch relativ schnell aber
egal ich bleib einfach mal beim laufen
wie ich meine das sieht jedoch keine
energie oder irgendwie sowas
ja
klar haben wir und zwar lege ich jetzt
hier das play rezept rein
so und jetzt muss hier kommt dieses
dings rezeptfrei mit den kletterten so
das was ich jetzt noch brauchen ist
warte ich befüllt die einfach mal schon
mal mit lava l mit wasser ich behalte
ich muss jetzt hier somit rechtzeitig
drauf machen so zack zack zack zack
moment
zack zack ihr seht jetzt erstmal nix
aber wenn ich drauf league gesicht ist
was da drin das wasser drin wasser
bleibe hier ist er halt in dem lager
spot noch nix drin
deswegen muss schätzt an der netter
gehen und ein bisschen lava holen
ich nehme einfach mal alle sachen mit
und hoffe ich sterbe nicht so leute
drücken die traum
es wird ja wohl nicht so schwer sein
dass ich im netz einfach mal so ein
bisschen lava abgreifen
es ist ja nicht mehr viele sind ja sechs
eimer alter wo bin ich gespannt
ok chillig ich bin direkt über sammler
weg ach wie geil dass meine beine
todesstelle oneda und ist ein gas alter
beiseite mit ihr mann
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen bock auf
gas vor allem weil die hürde bei mir
manchmal nicht so rum wächst das war
mein handy es hat mir echt leid gehört
weißwein liegt einfach mal direkt runter
und da unten sind noch so viele magie
teile ich will da nicht hin
ich suche mir eine andere halle ich hab
jetzt aber auch keine spitzhacke dabei
die egal aufwand einfach ein sehr schön
aber so laufen tut er auch mal ganz gut
da unten sieht gut aus
also ich bin direkt über sonst hätten
sie und ich gehe mal wieder hoch
ich wollte ganz genau wo bist du dich
ganz cool
klasse freut mich toll dass du da bist
geil machst du das ach man das überall
alter hut oder sind das mehrere ich weiß
nicht ich schaue mal auf der minimap
wartet kann man nicht irgendwie private
konsum so ging das nix da sieht man
nicht die ganzen mops ich brauche ja
weil ich will euch heiße gas nicht zu
nahe kam ich tue ich da nicht mal was
ich will hier doch nur um
ich habe schlechte erfahrungen mit
diesem ort leute da man hier ist aber so
ich habe das was ich brauche ich muss
weg statt des todes ach so ich hab den
waypoint so genannt lass mich hochwasser
wie war ich dann bin ich dann wenn ich
dann bin ich denn ich habe doch irgendwo
mir noch gemacht aber ich höre das ja
gut
ach jetzt im felsberger leben mit mir
egal